foreign
[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
what's going on you guys Lord addicts
here we're we're doing a
a what's what I'm looking for a preview
on as dust Falls you guys know uh it's
one of Xbox's probably most prominent
games coming out it's coming to Game
Pass day and day uh there is a feature
on here where you can play this with
more than one person it looks like you
played up to eight people uh kind of
like the Quarry where you know you go
back and forth on decisions in the game
uh keep in mind I don't really know too
much about this game Cog really wanted
us to to get at this and see this out
you know what's funny is we had to get a
new controller because I only had one so
we had to get that sonic blue man we had
to get that sonic blue uh so pretty much
how we're gonna do this is um I'm gonna
show you a couple couple hours of the
game not too much we're going to save
the best for for you guys for what you
actually play so any further Ado let's
get on to the actual game
bam we switching all right so as you can
see we already signed up you know the
addict or wolf all right that's you
wanted to be named okay just making sure
uh you know like I said eight people uh
but we're not gonna do eight we're just
doing two because we only got we want
six other friends man we friends list uh
so go ahead shut that door real quick
all right so we're gonna go ahead and
start this up now keep in mind like I
said
I don't know anything about this game
and she doesn't definitely know anything
about this game
but we're gonna go ahead and start I
mean you don't do you know anything
about the game
there you go see acting like
all right so it says explore move your
curses to find hidden interactions uh so
it does look like it's got a little bit
of like a point-and-click kind of
feature going
uh so you can you you can use this and
you can use this so all right oh okay
cool so that is that one so let's go to
push a
make decisions highlight your favorite
opinion and press a to decide and be on
your controller to deselect all right so
I don't know exactly how that works so I
don't know if we both can go at the same
time we're gonna find out here soon but
it does look like Press B on your
controller to deselect so I'm kind of
curious if we both pick something I
don't know we'll have to see
deadlock if there is no clear majority
decision was one of your selected
options will be to choose random so I
guess we could choose randomly we want
to think that's kind of like
counterproductive what the game actually
offers but it's pretty cool never seen
something like this
overrides that Cog did tell me about
this trigger and override to take over
any decision and give yourself the final
say you have limited numbers of
overrides use them widely wisely so if
you look up there at the top right
you'll see that there is overrides three
three three three I assume that's four
people we're not playing with four
playing with two so there's gonna be two
overrides up there it looks like we got
two override three overrides each and
pretty much what that's looking like is
like if I don't agree with something
she's doing some horrible decision I can
override it and she don't like what I'm
doing she can override herself so that's
kind of interesting you mean I can
override you no we are override you you
she ain't allowed to use her override so
that's the rule that's the rule
quick actions perform on-screen
instructions before the time eclipses to
complete quick actions go to settings
and quick play to change the action so
it looks like it's just up or down let's
look at
yes let's just swipe up pretty pretty
thing
personal insights at the end of each
chapter discover how your choices reveal
hidden insights about your values
personality and gameplay Style
that's pretty cool all right so let's
get this guy let's get this gold one man
let's get this going
there's grippers on this one too
all right so top here all right so we
have to go over here
you gotta move that yeah you go there
you go
gotta press a oh I'm red yes you're
right
well you read yellow
[Music]
my name is Zoe Walker
not so long ago
I wanted to be a journalist
it looks like you're about to drown I
just want to hold my breath
and this better hold your breath don't
look like you was holding your breath
not because I want to black out
she got like a timer on his beforehand
and thoughts die
and memories
90 seconds
90 seconds that's about how long it
takes for me
I wish I could hold my breath for 90
seconds
90 seconds is a long time I felt like I
would drown before okay actually you
know what you could do you could like if
you're holding your breath in you can
like breathe it out and then like catch
the air bubbles and stuff this isn't a
video game May the 29th 1999 I think it
said
you got to be careful because you could
you could Daddy are we gonna play
sorry pumpkin you bet we're gonna play
now I know you're an expert but are you
sure you've looked at everything
trust me I got this
okay she got this then what color
is
all right so explore the same move
around all right so we got the restroom
over here
okay sure I'm not gonna argue with you
yet
big truck
um that big truck way up there that
looks dangerous
okay smarty how about the exhaust pipe
um that's where all the smoke comes down
[Music]
hey you
were rocking this today Zoe that seems a
little dangerous that truck up there
like that yeah
play it probably not there's no way
one last look around
foreign
I already did it once I don't know why
it didn't do it again
ready
uh
are we ready or not ready no definitely
not are you ready okay then I'm ready
okay shoot
um how many stars are on my backpack
hmm
oh I didn't even check
oh
that's Peak
yeah let's peek I wonder if she's gonna
pay attention
let's just yeah you go there you go
there you go three no no six six it was
six it was six
almost don't click save it at six I
didn't
he was about to click six this is a
toughie
is it six
you cheated me I would never I
thought I totally cheated not gonna lie
are you okay I totally we totally
changed
[Music]
I'm sure he was just playing
come on back in the car
we still got 45 States license plates to
spot
hey hey
you
you doing okay yeah sure
it's going on back there you know I'm
fine Michelle we're good
why are you guys acting weird again
it's nothing hun just a long trip
I tell you the only thing worse than
feeding a dog fast food is smelling it
again on the way out Grandpa wait I'm
your grandpa all this time I thought you
were Minecraft
how far did you walk I was worried you
got lost oh just to the tree you know
dogs they think they're the ones holding
the leash
uh
all right crew buckle up I didn't want
to make it down Albuquerque before we
stop for the night
you're listening to drive time
flagstaff's first and finest it's
another beautiful Arizona afternoon and
your weekend
starts here
[Music]
so what's next license plate game
another round of row row row it was
definitely a song she fell asleep
halfway through here
keeping her entertained I am not
entertaining because I heard shepherding
oh you are my flock and I plan to hurt
you
in High Spirits
nice try wasn't taking the scenic route
your idea I wanted to do this trip at 30
000 feet
I'm not complaining about the drive I'm
just
just picture events living in
the middle it'll be great look I'll
surprise
which one you want to do pretend
pretend pretend it's a vacation okay
it's a vacation
let's just pretend this is a vacation
family trip Route 66 we collect a few
pressed pennies
and then back to Sacramento
can't
our life anymore look I'm just trying to
stay positive
all right so clearly something's up
you've got your tenure I've got
my new job
[Music]
couldn't make me work for a pet food
company if it was the only job left in
the country Jim I don't think that's
helping
ten thousand bucks you should have gone
for the jungular sued those bastards at
the airline the way they pinned that
thing on you not signed some settlement
paper I haven't signed it yet but you
still want to right what's going on I
know it's your call but I think it's
time to put this whole thing behind us
I need time to think
every man does oh my God why you gotta
be so extra give me a little space on
this one okay it wouldn't be fun if I
was an extra babe
mm-hmm
thank goodness he didn't run over the
lizard Vince was a good kid but he
always did let people walk all over him
I mean he was small you asked me to buy
you these cheap action figures so you'd
have somebody to give the kids at school
when they picked them what was that like
in high school huh
ouch
sorry
I do feel like they should have been a
little bit more
hyper focusing on who's talking like
obviously there's two dudes but I feel
like they should have like kind of like
blurred one of them out or something
yeah let's Let Them Fight
well Zoe appreciates me even if no one
else does
oh look at her little face she wouldn't
even make an old man feel he was
oh God swipe
yo what's got us killed no I didn't Mash
mash
what are you doing woman
I won't okay that
that kind of came out of nowhere are you
okay pumpkin
she's just shaking I think
in real life like if you did that
how How would how is there like an oil
maybe someone did it remember hey
thanks for coming back
right [ __ ] are you kidding me
country kids always there's a person
luckily we're still in one piece look at
the face okay the wheel is bent like
look at it
it's pretty bad they ain't going nowhere
it's like I feel like someone did that
though
that seemed intentional
the look on his face I hope he didn't
see our lives
yeah stupid [ __ ] was too busy yelling
into the wind
[Music]
that's the one
28 Northwoods
ugly as hell these houses all look the
same to me
Jay
you ready
Jay
what head out of the clouds little bro
come on he'll pull his weight
look this is just like we talked about
there's enough cash in that shape to put
the last five oh they're about to roll
up someone we stay alive we keep the
house everything goes back to normal
all right we're here what if we fail
sure they're they're not home seems
dangerous is this dude who lives here
you haven't told me whose house this is
it doesn't matter who
you're always outskoking in the woods
climbing trees and all that we all know
you're good at it
and you want to help the family right
you know I do then here's your chance
hop that fence and find a way in whoa
does Mom know you took that nope but
someone's got to watch your backs
we got one hour before their home if you
hear three honks you run like hell hey
let's party Dale
the code Jake and Tarzan [ __ ] over
the back gate I'll try I have a feeling
this is about to go wrong never know
when he might get lucky
please
play just a very mean looking dog you
gotta get in the thing a little bit oh
all right so we sneak past throw the
stick or talk to
uh first it throw a stick okay
distracted
I wonder if that's gonna work hey I feel
like talking to him
[Applause]
oh
my God
hell
foreign
that dog does not like
do you remember the code 5926
no at all do you remember I think it was
juicy
not funny what happened he's got a
Doberman
I had to lock it in the shed
those four numbers idiot
I mean we'll put it in what's the worst
that can happen
oh we should have wrote that down I
wasn't even thinking
it's a cop that lives here
whose house is this
Dante Romero
King of the pigs
wait the sheriff yep do you know Moss
beef with him goes way back
even before he sent me to juvie I know
but but what way I see it he owes us
so we ought to [ __ ] this place up a
little while we're at it
stick to the plan let's stick to the
plan oh boy's getting too emotional just
because he's definitely we only have an
hour maybe we should start looking for
the safe ah
whatever
what'd you do that for they might test
it or something oh come on
this is two rock you literally you said
you went to do me what did that means
yeah yeah
he's not that bright babe clearly
check painting that's probably where
safe is would be a pain
[Music]
behind the painting
yeah good place to hide a safe
no safe or not
um check out now oh there's a wallet
there
okay A little bit of money some monies
he left his wallet
told you he's an idiot so if the
wallet's there he might be there
all right so you doing
leave the cat yeah yeah because we don't
want to suspect him
spec but if we take in the the safe
money why does it matter if we leave the
cash because he needs a little bit of
cash to
you find another cover he put our
brother in juvie why do we care what he
wants
yeah but the brother's nice yes
he doesn't really want to do this so we
shouldn't make him do things it's for my
girlfriend you don't have a girlfriend
shut up I'm working on it
this is the idiot that you take on life
gives you lemons on a heist that you can
end up going to jail because come here
help me get a little payback
maybe next time yeah
yeah because we only have an hour ah
no
I did not you did not just help him to
go anyway are you serious
what just
sometimes I forget you're a hoe
all right enough screwing around
you look upstairs and I'll check the
rest of the rooms down disgusting just
thinking about the cob drinking there
yeah
you can actually drink pee but only once
only ones only once
I feel like there's someone here I don't
know why
the question is would you really do it
though oh God
or his wife who are you
[Music]
what are we gonna do
Route 66 Arizona all right this is
getting kind of chaotic 12 years
repairing jumbo Jets you think they
definitely fix a car don't take much
time to get right into it
yeah
sure
seen one Motel you've seen them all
[Music]
go and not go on ahead
you guys go on
Ryan's mom said I could stay over
tonight don't wait up you guys go on my
head
[Music]
hello
your time
[Music]
all right do we ring it or do we wait
ring bell
I don't know how to use the overrides
do we ring in again or do we wait what
about
them string again let's be annoying
okay we didn't ask all that I agree too
rich chill out man Jesus what does she
just do hi
we got in an accident a few miles east
of here
I don't suppose you have a couple of
empty rooms and the number for a tow
truck oh no dice our mechanics away in
Tucson for the weekend
oh it's wrong all right then just the
two rooms that'll be 70.
cash only
cash
I've got uh 52. that's enough for one
room hey Joyce I'm doing something
what do we get one room well just get
one room
stick them all in there stick them all
in there stick them all in there you
know how they got like a bed or two beds
and sometimes like a couch or a chair
there's a Nook
hi I'm Michelle thanks so much for
accommodating us well we're not exactly
full
glad to help
once again
problem with not having Breakers just oh
hey we're having breakfast
do me a favor go ask Norma to tell this
guy's car back here to the lot ah dang
you burst a tire or something
I'm pretty good at fixing stuff engine
problem actually but you're welcome to
try
it's a red SUV East you can't miss it
I'm on it
I'm on it
hey um do I know you no people just
mistake me for Clint Eastwood
good
ah thank God we're out of that heat see
look too big
are we on vacation now do we get to go
in the pool oh you know what our
swimsuits are in the moving truck and
stop jumping on the bed okay then
hey I said I said I'm jumping I'll stop
if you let me watch my show it's
educational
better watch
not me
that's right that's right I win don't
let you watch the nature Channel if
you're not even listening
ah this is it fair how about we all
watch a movie together before bed I
ain't no cat either
I don't know you're always salty it
feels pretty easy in real life
wow this is cozy who am I sharing a bed
with yours truly
fair warning I spoon in my sleep
why the long face
wait I know you miss me is that it she's
just had a long day
like all of us somebody I'm gonna take
Zeus for a walk Vince uh would you mind
joining me didn't we just walk a mile
well he has to pee and I want to talk to
you about something
all right so who we staying with dude
I want to know how to use these
overrides
oh
oh we're going with Jim
it doesn't matter what you do we're
going with you I hate you we ain't going
she don't look like she wants to have
fun Jim looked like he know how to have
fun
we're going with you I wanted to go to
jail anyways no we going with you
yeah you guys will pick it because we
going would you ever regardless what you
have to say
I wanted to sure I'll come
okay no you didn't
reverse psychology no you didn't yeah
okay
he wanted to talk to him anyways
I wanted I wanted to be nice and see
what he wanted to talk about yeah
didn't mean to cause a fuss in the car
earlier
so on edge
are you about to give me marriage advice
because if I recall you walked out on
yours no no
I just wanted to say thank you
for these last few months
getting to know you again getting to
know Zoe it's been a blessing I'm glad
she got to meet you
that's a weak throw the worst part about
living with it
it's a small dog having this tumor in my
head
fear of death living with uncertainty
regarding your choices
which one we doing
we not fearing to death living within
Services probably choices
it's probably having to look back on a
lifetime of shitty decisions yeah that's
you got me packed
I Disappeared for 30 years
I can only imagine how that must have
been for you and your mother
oh sorry
get high and
flip off the world what if you switch
those two around the world don't
complain to me sounds kind of fun you're
here now
you're here now all right all right I
just this one time
my door in the end
that couldn't have been easy
I appreciate that I know it wasn't
I'm sorry so I am
and I know I've done nothing to wear in
your trust but I need to ask you
something
okay the doctors
they say I might have as little as two
years they don't have a clue of course
but
well I know you said you could drop me
and Tulsa that I tracked down some
friends there just spit it out Jim can I
stay with you how would you feel about
me living in a new house with you and
Zoe and Michelle are you serious six
months ago I didn't even know you were
alive
now you want me to
to connect do you want to be sick in the
hospital
any time can I stay with you
it's not good I'll talk to Michelle
I kind of want to just shut him down
[Laughter]
always take it up with
you didn't just say we going we talking
to Michelle we talking to Michelle
you never make a decision without your
wife come on let's go celebrate
happy
oh hey there
got your car towed back for you you were
right it's more than I can fix with duct
tape and a socket wrench what do I owe
you nothing your guests
what in the world
oh we're getting robbed
oh oh
crap
do it
I'ma refuse
yeah I'm not getting shot okay yeah we
have a family man
good boy
30 minutes earlier Sheraton Taylor's
house
now hang on
you don't need to call for help
call for help
[Music]
yang
soft wheelchair yay Cowboy let's stop
the wheelchair
who wins yes
oh
[Music]
he did that with some aggressiveness
right there
shave
nobody's gonna hurt you okay
oh she can't hold it sorry
look we just came for the money then
we're gone
is she gonna tell us where the safe is
what money
all the mall the wife don't know about
the money I don't know don't you know
doesn't he tell you
he never tells me anything oh
I'm sorry I shouldn't pry
that really seemed
just I mean
try the office oh she oh she helping us
yeah I I mess with this [ __ ] it's his
own fault
do we believe her thank you
[Music]
shut the door
shut the door everything okay up there
it's fine I'm gonna try his office that
a boy
all right so where do you think the safe
is nice to be in here
let's look around
check the desk
I feel like we need to check the
painting
It's Not underneath there we'll check
the bookshelf
you know what happened here
that's interesting
now I want to kind of check everything
the poker bookshelf might be a fake book
or it's just like 11 book or something
yeah
yeah birds are very Zone yeah bird
watching
that's cool
are you just steal the book it's just a
book babe
I mean we are still don't look outside
because people will see it you in inside
check the bit I feel like we should look
outside why I don't know hey there's a
key
all right check this out drawer
remember the code no I don't do you
five six nine
gross two five six nine two it's
something like that numbers
you should search the bookshelf again
it's letting her search it again
probably use the key now yeah
found it
what the
where's the code
all right so what do you think it is I
think it's five two nine six five two
nine six
uh
[Music]
come on
okay oh God
[Music]
six five two five nine six
five
let's try
one two five
nine six that's four
all right
Dale
I lost the code I lost the
no you didn't
Tyler's gonna be pissed
hey I didn't know
that's why we got Plan B help me with
this that's not gonna work man ah
oh [ __ ] I almost had it though
oh God
foreign
[Music]
it's about to get serious but uh yeah
I think we need to go
watch it imagine
I go out the back door
no it's back door damn it what are you
doing
not coming up just came from my wallet
got your PT rescheduled for Monday by
the way
do you really think she heard you fam
I don't know I feel like that was a
little too loud I mean too soft
he's about to drink that
front door
now horrible
swipe oh my God you barely made that
still did it though
you got
I didn't know that like it's individual
people now
it's ten then go
who are you
just a guy who wanted a VCR
[Music]
how about I shoot you for breaking and
entering I Surrender okay
on your knees hands behind your head
oh God what's about to happen I got a 13
506 in progress at 28 Northwood Drive
same back up now
no I got
it oh why are you gonna leave the homie
like that you kind of like that Harley
like that
see
oh God
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
come on
I can't believe you just ran off about
came back early I don't know what
happened put myself in that situation
you gonna run off oh we got it all right
if I get him distracted away from you
then this person that surrendered could
have got him and just thought it
happened
[Music]
now
they didn't see us turn in
no they would have slowed listen up
we're not here to hurt you we don't even
want your wallets we just need a place
to lay low until we can be safely on our
way don't do anything stupid and you'll
be fine understood
please let's go
I think yes is the right how can we
trust you okay okay
how can we trust you let's see let's go
to sleep
we shouldn't even be here that makes two
of us just do as I say and we'll all be
gone in no time
[Music]
it's all right
car drive back the other way before they
realize they're not chasing anyone
too risky if they got roadblocks
we need to do something
do we try to negotiate just stay quiet
try to negotiate yeah let's try
um
you do whatever you want why are you
serious why are you gonna override my
thing it's because I'm making the
decisions in this world fine go hurry up
or you're gonna lose your turn
that's right what happened that's right
what look I get that you need to hide
but do you need us for that we could go
to our room stay out of your room no
one's leaving just stay down and stay
quiet
at least you tried
can't stay here
we can Until Dark
then we sit out cross country it's our
best shot I'm telling you we gotta drop
the weapon
oh
I just drop it
she means it
look I don't know her very well
but I think she means business no one
asked you he's right though I go down to
the range twice a week
Joyce if that thing goes off then I'll
scrape them off the walls
don't have to be like that
if we help these boys out of whatever
Corner they got themselves stuck in I'm
not helping them with [ __ ]
show me your faces
I said take off the masks
uh oh
yeah
Oh no you're the Hulk boys
you're the ones who hit our car
Paul
take the shotgun
I
I'm sorry I can't
Christ really Paul
you
grab the gun
holy rip
he really lets us do it now point it at
him
you do that I promise you'll regret it
we ain't
you've never first off
he's holding it with one hand yeah
there's too much force in that yeah if
he shot that it'll be bam right in the
face that's [ __ ]
you touch my things again you won't be
happy
hey you get the truck it away it's it's
in a shutout back
Tyler
these people didn't do anything
um
you and Dale line them all up
I need to make a call
line them up
it's me
we got a problem
desert Green motel
all right [ __ ] over by the tables
you boys
you haven't heard anyone have you ah we
killed the president
ain't that right bro you're the metal
brother
the one who got himself sent off to
juvenile hall shut the [ __ ] up why oh
God everybody knows Joyce don't from
what I hear
you're just like your daddy
another [ __ ] up halt thinks the
world's his to break
what like this
how about this
juice
shut it up now he's a dog he doesn't
have an off-sweet it's just nervous deal
I don't care what it feels I want it to
shut up
Palm dog
oh
oh they're gonna hurt the dog if we
don't fix this
oh hey hey Zeus remember me oh shut the
[ __ ] up oh Dale what are you doing it's
called controlling the room by putting
guns at puppies
I wasn't breaking the casting boys jaw
enough for you don't you start with me
or what you'll break my face too are you
just gonna shoot me
Zeus quiet
[Music]
I would ask you I'm Gonna Keep no ask
Joyce to back off because of
what I want to do
okay you're gonna get everybody
[Music]
all majority must agree asteroids to
back off no I feel like why do we owe
loyalty to this random chick no I'm not
saying that because she's she's going
against the guy that has the gun so how
do you think that guy with the gun is
going to feel well who cares if she gets
shot it's our dog yeah but
I feel like the dog could just calm down
on its own
rock paper scissors no just rock paper
scissors
[Music]
give him here
that's a good boy nice and calm
look at his face
man
uses easy there are you happy
see who was right it was wrong
[Music]
we will listen to you it would have been
a rap it would have been a rat I'm tired
of yet
taper mouth shut
oh now you gotta get the now you got
this let's find at least people lived
who cares if she gets her mouth taped
she probably liked that anyway that's
that's trauma
[Music]
oh yeah I refuse with you
huh
do your own Dirty Work
oh
wake up
why is there so much luggage in your SUV
because we're moving
you idiot who else are you traveling
with huh you tell me the truth now
my family
or just my dad tell him tell him the
truth the circus I don't know babe
because because what if his family walks
in and he they get shot
I think we should tell him the truth
babe you gotta protect
or she doesn't know I say we say the
circus because I mean are we really
wrong
we don't want to lie to him babe
because then if he finds out we're lying
he's gonna kill us all
I'm gonna say the circus okay I'm gonna
see my phone
we must agree on one of them I I just
personally feel like
telling him the family he's just gonna
put them In Harm's Way
you're not gonna budge actually I
don't know how do I how do I you have to
click my family
I don't want to do it
I don't wanna you just wasted it no I
didn't
oh I did
find the circus well I would say family
I just wanted you to use your overall I
hate you
my family
my father my wife my little girl go
check the rooms
you know something
I don't like you
first sign of trouble and you sell out
your own family
you're scared shitless right now
tell me I'm wrong
what what what's going on what happened
what wronged
you're right
okay you're wrong first thing about who
I am don't I
nope
with this tough guy Act of yours
that I can see through let's just hope
your walks as cool as your talk
what do we do that's just big Sam he
buys a soda talks for a while then he's
gone
Jay in the back
get rid of the cop hear me show a thing
boss
get rid of the car YouTube keep your
mouth shut and this will all be over
fast
you're coming with me
[Music]
hey there evening hey Sam
Paul how's things
slow as usual yeah like my daddy always
said if you don't slow down you don't
see the wall before you hit it
where's Joyce and her kid
upstairs
at a friend's house
isn't feeling well I evidently remember
sorry to hear that
you're right I have a feeling it's going
to blow up in our face but you and
[Music]
nope been here all day
are you liking the desert dream oh uh I
can't complain yeah Joey surrounds
yourself a tight ship
oh
look they wouldn't know about the family
if we didn't tell them ask what brings
you to two Rock
vacation
we're headed to Mexico for a little r r
oh my wife and I love it there which
city
nice
Mexico City
um
Mexico City really
it's not safe for tourists these days
we're gonna volunteer saving the orphans
where are you at this dude really not
gonna see the blood on the foot I'm on
my way back
anyway we're looking for three idiots
who broke into the sheriff's house if
you can believe anyone would be that
stupid
they're armed and dangerous so if you
hear anything you call 9-1-1
any idea who it was nah they covered
their faces so they wouldn't be
recognized oh is that why
[Laughter]
well he sees it now
is this one of Joyce's oh she was just
looking for that
I thought she was sick in bed
wait
is that blood
oh it's about to happen are you sure
everything's okay here
help help help
say help
[Music]
they're gonna shoot the call
[Music]
for Becca now
soon as I walk out that door I'm going
to radio for backup
now laugh like I told you a joke
good one right
take care now
what did he say huh
does he know
he doesn't he doesn't
of course no
he just told me a dirty joke what joke
about the manager
I swear to God he has no idea
watch the old man sell himself daddy
what's happening
oh God
oh
all right
look at the dog
Dale Jay we're leaving early
taking her oh wait no hang on
if we get away without being followed a
dropper to pay phone but if you call the
cops
attack him grab this gun what are we
doing babe
no we gotta grab his gun Becky don't do
nothing
he doesn't know how to use a gun though
oh no
I got you honey oh he's gonna get shot
what are you doing I swiped
oh
almost it's your turn
smash
look down
oh it's your turn
what's that
[Music]
shoot him
let go of me
look at that creepy look
well now
look who ain't afraid to hold a gun
anymore
tell him to let her go
if I did that it wouldn't be a standoff
look at that weird face
toys for once is this really what you
want in front of your kid
oh we could shoot him
what do you think we should do
[Music]
well if he shoots him then he gets shot
do you really want the dad to get shot
let's shoot him no let's shoot him no
let's shoot let's not
let's shoot him let's not
we should shoot him no
come on no you know you want to save
everyone
hey when is not when is it yeah but if
he gets shot please listen to me ever
been bad
think about it just think about it what
am I overall oh
[Music]
I feel like
we gotta choose surrender we got to
shoot still we'll have the gun and he
won't no surrender isn't he's gonna get
his gun up
you'll surrender and keep the guns
that's not an option that is an officer
he has the gun Tyler surrender
Tyler needs to go down yeah but if he
gets shot the dad gets shot shoot Tyler
hey the dad's gonna die if we shoot
Tyler we got to shoot Tyler I'm standing
strong on this okay you know what if if
the dad gets shot I'm killing you
[Music]
close your eyes
it's empty
whoo
oh oh God
made decisions without hesitating that's
you
that is so you coming to rarely changes
the choice once made
deadlocks 12.
values family
tries to prevent harm and protects okay
but here's the thing seeks to comfort
and reassure others unafraid of
Confrontation and physical danger you
have bad traits I have good traits I
feel like those are the traits you look
for seek comfort you need to seek help
[Music]
oh
man look at all the different
decisions you can make
[Music]
you think he does
what do you think he does well I told
him to shoot him okay let's go
why does it say A you for me
[Music]
you were gonna shoot point blank with a
shotgun in front of your whole family
I
it wasn't loaded
I told you I wasn't going to hurt anyone
but you were just ready to do it huh
for my family
oh
you're trying to kidnap my wife man
you think I'm just gonna stand here and
let that happen
Dale get the duffel bag we're out of
here
huh
cat guys
yes
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's Dante
he'll get us out of here if Dante you've
got more faith in him than I do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought we shot him
damn that hurt s yeah okay
it does tell you on the top left that
there's like an outcome that led to
decisions Department
did you [ __ ] know that already
the good news is a class straight felony
you can practically get off with a
warning
the bad news is
broken to my house and shocked me
I wasn't wearing my vest they even find
us
someone called 9-1-1
Jay Jake they can't get in the back
people are smart you'll save me some
trouble and just give yourselves up
all right what are we doing what are we
doing
I'm talking with this [ __ ]
right
Dante will get us out he's too
strong-minded for his own good half the
time
but he gets things done
all right you don't know what's his deal
what do you want to do babe
what are we doing you know him well you
know okay well you know him well I gotta
say my overrides for what it matters I
I'm prematurely used all my overrides
small town
everyone knows everyone
wonder if he knows Ash isn't here
tonight Ash is your son
yeah
best thing I ever did
we're sitting ducks here I say we stick
to the plan take our chances with a
hostage
the back Gates chained up there's no way
in
Tyler
I don't know
maybe we should just give ourselves
don't say it
Romero's impatient in these small town
cops couldn't catch a cold our best move
is to wait
is someone gonna get that
negotiator
the police are going to catch you and
put you in jail you cut it out or I'll
put you in a corner hey you can't talk
to my granddaughter like that she's six
years old she's just speaking her mind
yeah I'm speaking my mind enough
next person who talks is going in the
back office
you could reach Dante without them
knowing
oh what are we doing
calmly Define or we're just going to
straight off from Salt and yeah let's
crack a joke
we were trying to shoot Tyler a minute
ago now we're cracking jokes
hey guys
what do bank robbers eat for dessert
ice cream
yeah you're an idiot you know that I
mean it was kind of funny you see he
gets it
you just don't have a sense of humor all
right that's it into the back
no
don't separate us he'll stay quiet sure
it's fine it's not fine
none of this is fine I think you both
need a little time out jay make sure
nobody answers the damn phone
[Music]
oh
keep your mouth shut and don't make me
coming I wonder how we're gonna get out
they can obviously stand up
what's that all about it's going to be
hard to stand up though share of course
again
can you get your hands free
tight all right how do we do this
friction Maybe
or we use scissors scissors
or we use scissors thank you to the
floor
scissors
if we make too much noise
that's it
it's gonna fall try to cover the noise
I'll cough
on three
one
two
three
if it's the cops they're gonna keep
calling
the scissors
stop looking at you picking at your
fingers
I can't help it
hold what hold hey oh there's a big a
there
I'm in the desert Trail myself and you
connect me directly to the sheriff
Sheriff Romero who am I talking to my
name is Vincent Walker and I'm
a family we're hostages in here
I can help you I just gotta relax those
nerves first all right I may not have
much time
I get it so what can you tell me about
what's going on in there
it's always scared my dad is sick
the Moto staff has saved his last name
is Holt yeah here we go
let's ride him out let's tell him who it
is
the people doing this there's three of
them
the manager said there the um
the Holt boys
oh [ __ ]
well that explains a few things yeah
like what so
but tonight's going to be the end of it
what else
you're good keep going
what does that just one's just a
teenager one's just a teenager
the youngest brother the one they call
Jay
he's just a kid I don't even think he
wants to be here probably bullied into
it but
it's good to identify a weak link for us
and and for you
ah
hey
they've blocked the door
[ __ ] [ __ ] Vince this door won't hold
that was a psycho
[Music]
the middle brother I think his name's
Dale
seems sort of a loose cannon maybe yeah
yes Dale caught him assault in a liquor
store owner a few years back
somehow he thinks it was my fault I'm
almost out of time
we're gonna put it into this thing we're
gonna put it into it
[Music]
the time you talk to one of my hostages
behind my back I take him to the window
and shoot him
if your people 30 yards from the motel
and don't call us again
what did you tell him
well nothing nothing we ain't telling
you nothing
nothing
I didn't have time you're lying to me
he's not they barely said hello
these cops they might work for the
county but they are loyal to him and he
does not care about any of us and you do
leaving you two Alone Together was a
dumb idea let's go that hurts
I have a feeling the cops gonna being
the bad guy
I'm gonna shave your
stop it
trim it stop it
[Music]
as dusk
Falls
so at night let's see
12 years as a flight mechanic pretty
high up then one day bam
bits of engine all over the hanger
two workers hospitalized another in the
morgue all because you left the lug nut
loose on a DC-10 no that wasn't me
it was a faulty compressor disc
and the airline was cutting Corners I
kept warning them but it's still your
word against theirs
my advice
signed the form take the money it's a
generous offer it's a gag order
if I sign that it's professional suicide
look I keep the check
we won't even cover my rent for a year
all I want
use my job back Mr Walker with all due
respect you'll never work for an airline
again regardless
yourself a favor
of the pen
what desk
we're gonna flip the desk okay let's
flip it
I mean do we really need to flip it
though why can't we there be like a
third option it's like no dude
right up your ass
oh so you do have a little fight later
[Music]
[ __ ]
two days before then
hello
uh yeah yeah
I just had the strangest dream I was
back in the lawyer's office a dream
time of day while I was packing you know
like dreaming it's nice like a Daydream
Missouri huh like a Daydream as long as
everything's box up and in good shape
for the landlord
step stress but
I've got a really good vibe about it
Vince we'll be back by seven
I'm just gonna pick up Chinese
Zoe
Chinese sorry gotta go sure okay it
sounds good actually
we should get some rice for dinner
tonight
huh
we already got the all right you got
into seven to get this apartment ready
to go
okay let's go buy some rice and put it
with it
I think that'll work oh my gosh I wish
we had
who cares about the AC at this point go
outside
check the box
five boxes
okay I'm gonna wash the dishes because
you say I never watched dishes in real
life make dessert for them come on make
dessert for them when they get home they
have dessert okay hold up hold up hold
up let's let's be realistic here all
right
if you was coming home what would you
want more the dish is done or dessert
yeah dishes
you see I told you
right I know women
not really oh oh
[Music]
swipe down all right good girl
now let's let now let's make dessert
it's done then make that I wish I could
have washed dishes that fast
we had chocolate pudding the day we
moved in so
why not go out in style
ew
that boat was kind of disgusting I had
chocolate pudding in it huh be strong
Vince step away from the chocolate
[Music]
yeah we're good we're good
what's next
okay pack boxes all right
I feel like if we do the AC he's gonna
get shocked
some dreams never get off the ground
[Music]
all right on the home stretch now
pack photos yeah like photos though
[Music]
photos
they're moving we packing we ain't
looking we packing
debating off you want to look at the
photos
[Music]
it's because the game knows I'm right
foreign
[Music]
I'm just saying maybe he would find a
clue in the photos
check the now let's fix the AC fine
let's fix the AC probably gonna be one
of those mini games
this is anything like the cold air unit
on a flight deck there should be well
this is obviously alien technology
oh you barely made that
cool Imperial thermostat control
C by Vince
though
and she's still gonna be mad
I went and did all that and she's still
gonna be mad how was your last day
okay I guess really gave me her address
but I'm gonna miss her no I hear you
it's a big change for everyone we'll
write to her as soon as we get to St
Louis okay gotta help mommy now why
don't you run upstairs and get your PJs
on are you gonna put me to bed tonight
sure thank you
sure thing kiddo kiddo I know you worked
hard today so I got you your favorite
oh
we really need to buy some rice
shrimp
by the way did the moving company call
um
nope
awesome you took care of everything
that's how men do it
no joke yeah
you say I'm too much I'm all jokes
hey Buster of course I did Vince's
moving company At Your Service why yes
we do accept tips that might be taking
it too far oh I don't know I'll be
living on handouts if I mess up this new
job
you remember what you told me when I got
laid off from the tax office
make sure you empty the stationary
cupboard on your way out no you told me
that change only hurts when you try to
stop it happening and you were right if
I hadn't gotten laid off I would never
have finished my PhD application or
gotten my job at the University I get it
focus on the positives
which is why I made
chocolate pudding
see I told you the dessert was
good call
told you and yet she's eating so he's
already eating the food she ain't eating
the chocolate pudding we're getting
ready the good food comes first
oh what what
he side-eyed that that text that she did
because she looked at let's get your
jammies on what texture Jenny's off
so
how are you feeling about the move
tomorrow
looking forward to it
I dreamed that the movers took my my
star lamp and I was so
scared because I never sleep in the dark
hey you know what I had a bad dream
recently about something I can't get off
my mind and I wish I could was it about
the dark no but
the thing about dreams is
maybe sometimes they're trying to tell
us something like what
it's okay to be scared we should face
our fears
we
've got to be more got to be more manly
around here
don't look at me like that try and get
some sleep okay
look all I'm saying is if you don't let
kids feel their feelings
they'll be not knowing how to control
their feelings when they get older I
don't think women with their feelings is
an issue hmm never mind this moving
company better show up tomorrow how hard
is it to send a confirmation message
settled already Mommy
Coming Love Bug
well there you go
I bet that's them right now
Bruce gonna miss your sweet little smile
cupcake one nice drink
who's Bruce
[Music]
does Bruce man being a little sus
at that one moment he's like do I really
need a wife
I need to get the hell out of here
foreign
okay that's the desk
could be useful
see we got a pin
okay whatever not see if we can use the
window and maybe pick it with the PIN go
to it
yeah
Maybe
you're right I'm always right the game
has showed you that this whole game
uh what else is here
try the door maybe
yeah try the door
hey
oh we're using the pen
oh God drop the stupid clip
maybe you have another chance oh where
is it where is it search watch it wait
what is it search it left or right
and obviously you was wrong so we're
searching the right now
guess where that pin was
a try oh
laughs
I can't believe that actually worked you
see anything no
dark out there
you can barely see us
how'd they not hear that
hey did you hear something
I'll check the back door
knock them out dude you like twice his
size
[Music]
so he's up there
scared of the dark
they're coming for you
you know that right shut up Joyce I'm
serious
how much you want to make a bet that
that's her baby daddy
you should join us take our chances I
think Joyce and the guy on the red plaid
keep quiet have history together it
sounded like him
Zoe it's me pumpkin it's Daddy
is that window open
listen
oh why are we hiding
hiding I don't know what else to do hey
it's me
it's Vince
I'm coming in
Daddy
I didn't hurt her
promise I know I heard him so we you
okay Daddy I I don't want to be here
anymore I know you said not to be scared
but I mean
um
holder type big
I am too pumpkin
it's okay
let it all out
let it out
you think they're gonna try to what's
that what's that uh
Frozen thing Let It Go Let It Go
forward him don't tell him warn him
let's warn him
I like the dude
I'm pretty sure
any minute now I don't want to go to
jail
and maybe you'd better hide listen I'm
gonna get us out of here before
the lights come back on
okay with Mommy and Grandpa of course
we won't leave them behind
story
[Music]
you know what he forgot to do shut the
door back
we get my earphones yeah
what I said he forgot to shut the door
back you guys all right
the doors that he found himself you
found her thank God we're the Holt
I think they went out the back
we need to get out of here
give me your wrist
will you hurting keep cutting it close
no are you
okay go everybody down
don't shoot we're not stitches
stay down and don't move
where are the perps
[Music]
Run for the door I'll cover you
get up
inches
this is getting serious
crisis Now or Never
we won't make it so we're just going to
come out of the corner with a rocket
launcher
stay again or run for it what do we do
babe I feel like if we run for it
someone's gonna get shot but I don't
care as long as I make it out
you're not in the game but if I make it
out so I'm projecting myself on to the
individual so as long as he makes it
foreign
for it even if someone gets shot okay
what if it's the kid babe you know how
bad that would be you can have another
kid
we you know we don't even have a kid you
can have another kid
whatever
run we have to go now
Michelle
is hit
I knew this was a bad idea
full fire repeat Hold Your Fire
I said 30 [ __ ] yards I wonder who you
try that again I shot every last one of
them leaves in a body bag
did I just get the kid the wife kill
yeah you did thanks I mean you agreed
with me
it's hard to argue with you or even have
the upper hand because you were I am
right mentality oh [ __ ] she's been
shocked
look what I did [ __ ] should be fair no
to be fair you literally have an
override switch oh my God I am done I'm
done I'm out of here
no serious cheers
she's right here
your Mommy needs some space darling yeah
she's basically let me get her before I
got her killed
you're the one said right for IT smash
smash
Dale go see if you can barricade the
second floor hmm
oh look at that shot man I know that
look
it's bad
isn't uh no
we're gonna be real with it
I don't want to lie to you because
there's
a lot of blood
you're wrong
nah
just spent 324 days in the jungle north
of Danae
saw a lot of these
what
I couldn't find the first aid kit but I
got some tweezers some pads
we're gonna take care of you honey
look it went in her back and didn't come
out the front since the bullet's still
in there we got to get it out then
or something don't we I don't know man
you dig around too much and they get
infections
and my hands Shake
if anyone's doing this it's you I don't
want it in Memphis please get it out
do we even think I'm qualified to remove
a bullet
if she dies this is on you
okay
we're doing fine here we go
oh Mash
tap
slice
it's okay
I've got it I've got it look how easy
that was nice job the doctors need eight
years
this here's the good stuff it usually
stays hidden
Paul's a recovery
two years sober this July
it's about the heart
but it's okay keep going
you should be all right for now we need
to keep the pressure on this wound
no no stop you listen to me
what I want is a helicopter or I start
killing hostages
that's right and safe passage to Mexico
Mexico
it's now
the boys are in way over your head
you're going to mail a burglary no no
spare me the lecture can you do it Dave
there I'll look into it imagine I need
to show a faith
the drug problems I ain't much of one
for faith
so let's make it practical no you must
be hungry for a hot meal all right
then I start on that helicopter I know
you forget something I want Mill enough
from that shitty joint in town
Franco's veggie Delight
give me 20 minutes
[Music]
good news folks one of you is going home
it's obviously the one that got shot
[Music]
no because if she
if she leaves she's going to this guy
that wants a tree
gonna miss your sweet little smile I
kind of got confirmation from the movers
tomorrow morning
good to go at least we get one last
California Sunset
we'll buy her one last drink
15 years ago I couldn't wait to leave St
Louis
first person
he's gonna bring it up eventually I'll
never forget that book of pride is she
gonna say you're only gonna say who
broke but you know what
I never realized how proud I'd feel to
be going back
I just wish it didn't involve so much
stuff oh is there anything more
stressful than moving
I hear divorce is stressful
she like you know anyway
tonight
huh and it seems so long since we you
know
sound
how about we make it one to remember
[Music]
you want to mention yes we're mentioning
the text
who's by the way you got a message
something about
cupcake why did you
events
you've been reading my messages
of course not Bruce we say who's Bruce
thought it was the movers thought it was
the movers we're gonna be
you want to tell me who Bruce it's hard
to not feel like I'm correct all the
time when the game is telling me I'm
quick
some things are private
did you really gonna play that card
it'll wake Zoey
he's got the house number two
well thank you it's been nice working
with you too
oh I'm sure you'll all do just fine
without me
hey do you mind if I um
hi is this Bruce uh
uh it is Bruce right
oh I hear you like cupcakes Vince give
me the phone
weird he hung up
what the hell has gotten into you what
are you what are you fighting about
this is getting real interesting
hey you should be in bed I I couldn't
sleep
what who's pretty
why is he calling you cupcake
we'll live together right we just
co-worker babe
always whenever she said always oh
really we're just co-workers and you
want the last drink with them yeah it's
the homies
you won't have
you won't have no one to call a hoe
bam
she's literally gonna brush
Bruce dude hmm
we did some research together on the
Ecuador I'm sure she did all types of
reasons babe
foreign
you know do you like him he's clever we
got on well professionally Academia is
competitive she's trying to look like
completely Wing this professional
looks like Patrick Swayze I know the
type
oh let's forget about all this don't let
it ruin our lives
got a long few days ahead of us
foreign
let's refuse it use one
what
hey you look at your
see that's what I wanted to do so that's
why the game chose it
something about it doesn't add up
you've been working late more than usual
because I
because I'm changing schools
I need to leave on a high note last week
you said that you had to stay in great
papers but you came back smelling of of
wine
and perfume look at me
Vince
I know things have been hard
this last year wasn't a great one for us
but nothing happened between me and
Bruce do you believe him can you please
believe me
believer
all right all right there's two ways
this can go no there's no there's my way
in the incorrect there's the shut up AJ
Ray
okay so there is the I'm sorry and we
can move on with our lives or the no
there's more to this but we're going to
be moving anyway so you'll never see the
dude again anyways so so what you're
saying is because we're moving out of
town it doesn't matter she cheated I see
that you would defend a woman you would
defend a woman no at this she's she's
done the wrong she's definitely in the
wrong then why don't we call her out all
right fine there's no no there's more to
this
talking about
it's okay
Michelle
every bone in my body tells me you're
sleeping with this guy now you're being
ridiculous all right then give me your
cell phone what I want to have a look at
your messages
oh you got something to hide no of
course not so what's the problem
oh yeah what's the problem what's the
problem lady there's more than one guy
what's the matter
it was a mistake oh
now we gotta get rid of her would you
would you would you take your girl back
if she cheated on you I was right
I don't know what to tell you
it doesn't happen look at her crying she
thinks that's I mean clearly he took her
back
was it good
you
wanted
to start yeah
oh my God you're that you're those types
I just wanted was you good in bed
yes
I don't know
that would make me happy but it just
made me feel worse
it was stupid
after the accident
neither of us were in a good place and
he was
I don't know
he was there
bed
do you love him
do you love him
I don't want to know how many times like
if somebody cheated on me I would not
yeah I wouldn't want to know that is it
yeah well I do love it
she's gonna say I don't know
tell me the truth I don't know do you
love him
that's not
I love you
every time I try to get close
she's talking conviction
every time I try to get close push me
away
[Laughter]
you betrayed me it's just never it's
never just sex what about our family
what about our family you have no shame
what about our family what about Zoe
did you even think what this could do to
her I didn't want to hurt anyone but she
said it was good fam she didn't care
about what it does to the family exactly
sure
I mean
I felt so rejected
so I'ma reject you you haven't touched
me in months months you haven't looked
at me
when was the last time we even watched a
movie together
last night
when you lost your job
this wall went up
you pretend everything's fine
that you don't need to talk but the wall
just gets higher and higher Brick by
Brick
and I missed you okay I miss you
so are we gonna let her blame oh
how dare you turn this back on me
trying to make you understand
she's trying to Gaslight us yeah I know
you're hurt and
but I can't undo what I did
you want revenge have a one-night stand
maybe I will I don't want that
really
it's not the point
I don't want to sleep with anyone else I
want you
Vince
I did a stupid
thing it was really like all right I get
Bruce for one night if I could take it
back I would that's funny
at least sit down so we can talk this
through
[Music]
is it worth sitting down and talking
wait what kiss I feel like we're not
getting like sit and talk but where is
the get out of my leave right there
there's the one I want
no because they're supposed to be
oh God
yo I don't appreciate that
my authority can you ever forgive me
that's going on Twitter okay
I think
you can forgive but still leave them
uh
all right so we got a couple scenarios
to go over here okay one we're leaving
for good she ain't never gonna see this
dude but will she cheat again
[Music]
I can't believe you you overrode my
override
I almost tried it again to override your
over would you override it again yeah I
will
Let It Go but it's gonna take time
talk about
him building a wall and then him
building a bigger wall
she's looking at him cheating
can't turn a wife into can't turn a hoe
into a light oh
she's gonna have to walk
Vince
don't let them send me out
no you're a piece away you're getting so
hurt honey you need to get to a hospital
I know I look like this but I
please
just get her somewhere safe
no Zoe gonna live will Michelle be okay
here
hard to say
I've seen it go a lot of different ways
I don't care who goes but only one of
them
I think we got us in the life
we got to she's hurt yeah but what if
she cheats
[Laughter]
said Michelle or I believe that if they
send the child out alone where's the
child gonna go with the cop in the
police station alone I don't think I
think she should stay with the family
okay then we'll send Michelle what's in
Michelle
you're cheating ass
she's gonna cheat on him with the cop
man just goes to you
let's get you to a surgeon who actually
went to Mexico no no no please
I'm all right listen to me you were shot
just open the door
okay take your cheating ass just push
you out in the front door
Zoey
Zoe come here lovebug
I love you so much
I love you that plus a hundred
take her out grab the food come on back
why couldn't we like offer to send like
the old dude
you dropped this
oh here we go her name's owl owl huh
you know they can see in the dark I
think we're just gonna like just jump up
just straight feet and just a feet
she's tough
she'll make it
okay they're coming out stay right where
you are stupid
why is Savory so she could cheat now you
know I'm gonna make cheating jokes
throughout the entire the yo be fun
you'll be fine you'll be fine you'll be
fine you cheated you'll be fine
see again this game is like then add a
big breath out we know your choice you
are the permanent ones
yoga answer after an hour
Rosie it's far enough a smoothie
I'm unarmed
I'm Sheriff Romero
I guess you must be Vince
where's that stretcher people let's go
what happened she was shot in the raid
looks like single entry no exit wound
blood pressure 60 over 30. I got the
bullet out Steve radio ahead and
activate a trauma team
thanks
I'm so sorry about what I did
oh I know you forgave me but
is that enough
she dies here be okay after all this
you can find a new
Moon that doesn't cheat
of course we will honey
you gotta let her know that it'll be
okay shoot it back at her whenever she's
out of the hospital gotta make sure
unless I guess like if she if she makes
it gotta make sure the paramedics how to
do no I want a woman
I do
hey that's enough talk
if your wife cheated I'll see you soon
okay
I don't know
it's good you got her out
she'll be awesome yeah but you guys are
married
through the good and the bad I know
there's a lot of bad though for you
[ __ ]
it's hard for me too
just [ __ ] shot me
but I've got good news yeah
we're about to have a man on the inside
[Music]
hang in there buddy
we're rooting for you
I pick him up and don't do anything
stupid
there's like eight people and then I got
three so I forget the napkins
two-way pager
enjoy your pizzas
he gave him a radio name
okay babe all right
radio not Radioactive radio it's the
pizza guy you're late no tip
[Music]
well what you know
cop kept his Pizza ain't hard
a helicopter though
look I know you didn't want this
but you got Romero wrapped around your
fingers
I love you I really hope you're right
don't forget 10 years saving up for this
place
Ash only just started to feel at home
how can we stay we didn't even see the
right of the walls a Fresh coat of paint
fresh cookies the glass you'll see it'll
be good as new because
it's not the walls it's what happened
within them
keep rubbing my back you like the back
rubs
I wonder what's gonna happen it's Mommy
gone
she's on her way to the hospital I'll
blow her a kiss to get better
so did you meet the sheriff out there
yeah you could say that
how did he get the pager
to them
he's intimidating he's up to something
he'll keep us safe
Are you seriously
there we go let's go
the game likes me within plans if you
did it because I was originally picking
that one so when I picked him
are you serious are you serious right
now I'm 100. it's still clear
don't share this but do that Dante's a
cousin him just block it out don't block
it out that was a good idea
what are you doing
I'm counting out cash that that mic is
really good you gonna eat
not hungry I want it to be over Tyler
all of it it'll be over when we win
you remember they win do your part
eat the pizza
Maybe
foreign
are you serious
hey
you want to share that with the rest of
us
um oh nope
don't think I do what's going on
[Music]
serious
are you deaf um
don't get caught that's what he's gonna
say
what do you mean we can't have any
for us so back the [ __ ] off you [ __ ]
Paul has low blood sugar
it's fine I lead from the vending
machine
we don't get to eat
[Music]
no I said no the answer is no
demand Pizza no we eating pizza
oh this chapter is probably come on man
just share the food
here you go getting all up in my [ __ ]
again why should I huh
demand
with your nonsense
oh [ __ ] sorry
idiot
clean it up
um
you know the trouble with you is
you get too [ __ ] involved if you just
stay quiet to begin with we'd be gone by
now
never thought of it like that
what you don't get is you're saying us
needed money but it's not like I made it
Tyler he built [ __ ] no Jay's into nature
me
yeah I Rob the liquor store once but I'm
getting the job soon
it's not here though why Jessica would
date me after this [ __ ] I got no idea
quicker than that
tell him a joke
sounds like some hard [ __ ] man oh [ __ ]
you no I'm being serious I see your
point well no sympathy [ __ ] I won't
see my point
Hallelujah hey I was just trying to you
what
feel sorry for me feel sorry go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ]
so uh does that mean no pizza
he's playing
I don't think pizza's happening guys oh
I wasn't hungry anyway
something's really going wrong here
why is this cop so interested in his
stuff
you got my helicopter
authorized The Landing
I want to have a talk
oh why you picked my house
face to face
out front
or there's no deal
what's he playing at some kind of trap
but right now we need to play his game
how about I go
I got some things I could say to him no
way oh God I told Mom I'd look after you
it's all right
put my big boy pants on today
you mess with us it's the hostages who
pay
s a boy
you and I going for a stroll oh God why
are we going tell Dante he better get us
out of here
what is it where are we going well
obviously we're going out we're going
apparently
I'm not fat
coming out why would we go to the cop's
house
I can't wait to be on a beach somewhere
eating tamales drinking tequila
you're delusional
they're never going to let you out of
the country you know that right
hey [ __ ] you
shut your mouth
please make it back
guess who
Dale Holt
I was expecting your brother Merry
[ __ ] Christmas sorry
I never thanked you from my shoulder I
was aiming for your heart
but I guess you got one
hmm
no you were small time before today
an ugly assault a couple Summers back I
saw that he theft oh but now look at you
it was sure I've made a name for
yourselves
I'll do you want better jackass
this is your lemonade
I believe you have something of mine
yeah your money
not the money
my black book
where is it the [ __ ] are you talking
about don't play games with me don't
step closer and I blow his [ __ ] head
off I swear tell me where it is I told
you already I don't know anything about
that
foreign
I bet you that black book is that
the birds book that he took
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
Target Tim I repeat targets
no you [ __ ] murderers
take them out take them out holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
you're not done go find the book
you don't know
I'm I'm still in shock what just
happened
you heard him they don't have it
[ __ ]
these boys are born Liars
I go inside if I were you
what did you do what did I do are you
[ __ ] serious why did you come back
because my family's in here
hey this isn't his fault
you're the one in charge Tyler you're
the one who let your brother go out
there you want to blame someone take a
look in the [ __ ]
Joyce
no
Tyler
[Music]
I wonder what happened if we would have
warned him
we wouldn't have gotten Joyce killed
I wonder if Joy Scott came
[Music]
on you think
[Music]
oh you didn't think about that before
[Music]
[Music]
oh God this is
maybe you're right maybe the cop is up
to something
[Music]
yeah because you said there might be
friends
[Music]
it's not that sensitive
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
quick throw and finding hot spots I'm a
quick thinker
cares for others
with these mother fail or whatever do
they just flip
flip faces danger with courage unafraid
of Confrontation and I didn't get to
read the rest of it
what's the blue
the blue is the regular timeline and the
uh the yellow is the past timeline
oh okay
looks like there's four different
endings for this chapter
look at this
so whatever happens right here kind of
like
um
all right so let's go ahead and
scroll back up to to the to the just
chatting
all right what's going on guys so uh we
we will be I'll be doing more of an
in-depth video I didn't mean to just
push you out I'm sorry we'll be doing
more of an in-depth video uh you know we
we did the first two chapters man it was
about two hours uh you know just
brief you know what actually we'll do
that video later uh appreciate it for
coming through uh you know I definitely
go follow me on Twitter Lord addict IOP
do you want to plug in your Twitter oh
she don't want you guys following her
she she ain't about you guys like that
I'm pretty sure I'm coming through
definitely you guys know where to go uh
for the actual review uh you know
hopefully it'll be on probably gonna be
on the Lords of gaming.net definitely go
check that out and without any further
Ado I hope you guys enjoyed the video
peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]